yo what up
episode 2 apostle hotcakes we're
bringing back the ruffle and flowered
hoodie popular
okay so episode 2 we're gonna be talking
about Elon Musk if you're gonna do
hotcakes
you gotta talk musk and today's episode
is gonna be talking about the short
first tweet which is Jess in might be
squeeze but first of all let's talk
about what is going on with Tesla and
there's a lot so this time last year
ExxonMobil the oil and gas guy
Tesla today Tesla is worth 250 billion
dollars excellent
think about this look at this one that's
Tesla that is mine Tesla was an eighth
of the minds blown unfortunately okay
anyways let's not talk about how fun
rich I am let's talk about Elon Musk
tweet from last week he tweeted out that
he's selling limited edition short
shorts and this is something that's been
in the works for a while and we were
gonna go through exactly what has led to
these short shorts he sat in the short
shorts when you go to the website is
absolutely hysterical so you can read
here is you can run like the winner in
teen like liberace with our satin and
gold design so actually on the back of
these shorts it's supposed on se XY sexy
and Ivonne musk has always joked that he
named his cardomom s3 next why does he
want to spout sexy sure enough that's
what he's done
let me explain to you why I think this
is the greatest mini so it interviewed
Yvonne tweeted that who controls the
memes controls in universe and I mean
this is just factually true if you
control memes you control mind share and
mind share as Leo sent an interception
that's everything once you're in the
brain there's
you're once an idea has taken hold in
the brain it's almost impossible to
eradicate so you are loved because
entire life is kind of me and I'm gonna
walk you through why these short shorts
might be the greatest ever so
specifically what I'm gonna touch on are
the shirts themselves the word short and
the price tag that he put on the shorts
69-420 and I think I can convince you
that this is like a mega mystery so
let's talk about the shorts themselves
for the uninitiated in investing in the
stock market when you want to bet
against the stock
you sure dit so you should sell it I'm
not gonna talk to the mechanics and what
that means but just know that shorting
the stock is betting against it and now
Tesla is one of the most shorted stocks
in the market and even though he doesn't
deliver the profits you would expect
from a typical car company he stole his
stock price just keeps going up and up
and up as I showed with excellent
example the most famous short seller
has been David I'd be former building
there keep that in mind
he runs a fun green light capital and in
he compared has the two Lehman Brothers
which was the investment bank that went
bankrupt and ultimately precipitated the
great financial crisis so what's so
funny about the Einhorn situation when
I'm home was a very vocal short seller
of Tesla and musk was very well aware of
this but musk had a good time with so we
turn on the Einhorn actually the least
must car and he came up to these
bloomberg reported it of course when
humoured reports this Elon the mean
master is going to jump on it have a
good time
look at the first response here it's
Elon Musk and he says tragic I will send
irony box of short shorts to comfort him
through this difficult time and this is
where it gets really good that was an
empty promise you won't actually reached
out to chubbies
the apparel company
and they tweet a new out street on it
fam and they prepared the box for short
shorts and if you're thinking to
yourself oh there's no chance that even
I don't actually receive this package
you would be mistaken so here's Dave
Einhorn tweeting that he received shorts
but he has also since then fallen out of
the Billy ring so that kind of wraps up
the short part of this short short name
and now I want to talk about the 69 420
the price that you and how he has
previously hinted at those names in the
past which are incredible first let's
talk for 20 in internet meme them for 20
refers to April 20th which is national
weed smoking big but two years ago woody
not must tweet it about the number 420
it was in reference to taking Tesla
right at four hundred twenty dollars a
share he said that funding was secured
and that this share price was at a
significant premium to the existing
public stock market price so this
obviously moved the stock quite
significantly but it turns out you can't
actually make these statements if
they're not true and Elon ended up
paying twenty million dollars to the
Security and Exchange Commission Tesla
also had she had said that Elon misled
the markets now if you're thinking to
yourself you know this is honest mistake
maybe you own just a little bit excited
and he had fundamentals around the
number 420 that is just not true it
turns out that Elon pick the number 420
in reference to the 420 meme and he did
it to impress his singer or a musical
artist girlfriend Grimes I want you to
think about that for a second youhad
must ended up paying 40 million along
with Tesla for what was accenting inside
pool on internet now that's the 420 part
of the 69 420 price tag you hug
wondering okay before
funny part I get that that makes a lot
of sense that tweet was pretty famous
what does 69 have to do Elon Musk here's
a little bit of detective work to
identify why 69 matters that you don't
musk
other than the fact that's 69 it's just
a hilarious internet Nene thing so Elon
Musk was born on June 28th and 420
member we've just referred to national
lead smoking is actually April 20th so
if you actually calculate tell me these
there are between those two dates you're
gonna come to a pretty funny number
sure enough the number is 69 there are
69 days between 4/20 and Elon Musk
birthday June 28th and if you think this
is just a coincidence I found that evil
musk is not aware up let me point you to
this tweet do I even have to read this
I'm not reading it this is so good okay
so what does this all mean means if you
control the memes you control the
universe and Elon clearly does you can
see from this chart up productive times
down first off Tesla is up the next day
and just from my end as a student of you
on this video is 489 second which is 420
+ 69 and I'm just doing that out of
respect for you thank you I'm student
you are the meme God short shorts for
everyone if you enjoyed this video
please leave some comments below
subscribe and now watch Elon Musk ask
you to stop its mr. short shorts
[Music]